cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com we have this from
noxnews.com oh this yup uh so Oliver
Anthony is in some kind of like there's
like some scandal going on where
basically he had this show at it's a
venue called Cotton Eye Joe
and it got canceled and then he came out
and said it was because if ticket prices
being too high but there's some
interesting stuff going on and I'm gonna
I'm gonna tell you right away uh I think
the dude's cool but I think look man
when you take someone from humble
beginnings and put him on a slingshot
straight to the Moon some gets
up real quick yeah so Knox news
reports this the uh the show was
canceled he said a new one it's already
sold out but I've got a couple posts
that I want to highlight
Chris Burton posted this video from
Oliver Anthony
Oliver Anthony cancels Cotton Eye Joe
show citing 90 to 200 tickets he said my
shows should never cost more than 40
bucks ideally no more than 25.
okay so when I saw this right away I was
like this is what happens and I mean no
disrespect when somebody who's never
been in the industry is launched right
into it and is shocked to discover why
prices cost so much it's because that's
how much it costs the immediate
assumption people had is like Oliver
Oliver Anthony's attitude is hey man I I
normally charge 25 for my shows yeah my
friend dude your shows were like 50
people in a small a small bar if you're
talking about a 1500 1 550 venue it's
gonna get crazier than this but here's
what breaks down
he made another video clarifying
Cotton-Eyed Joe posts this they said
it's a damn shame what the world's
gotten to for the customers of the world
famous cotton Joe most times we say a
show has been canceled due to
circumstances of piano control well we
are canceling the Oliver Anthony show
under our full control all refunds will
be made in the next few business days to
our original form of payment to to your
original form of payment the north man
of Richmond is that that's interesting
everyone yeah weird uh contracted to
play the Cotton-Eyed Joe for 120 000 for
60 minutes after doing the math and
knowing we can only hold approximately
1500 people paying the ticket website
their fee to sell the tickets paying the
tax man opening the Joe on a closed
night we set the ticket price to break
even and bring out uh bring our
customers a show we thought would be fun
to our talent agency and promoter
friends that follow us be careful
booking the north man of Richmond they
locked the post and Oliver Anthony
issued the statement he said Cotton Eye
Joe claims we are charging people 120
000 per show they have since turned the
comments off but I want to clarify the
most I've ever made on a show is thirty
five thousand dollars we've had two
shows in NC that were completely free
and another show that was scheduled
September 23rd in Kentucky for a cancer
benefit all right I'm gonna tell you
exactly what I think right now before we
jump into this because because Phil's
got tons of experience in this kind of
stuff
if the question is
did Oliver Anthony charge 120k for one
show his answer the most I've ever made
on a show is 35 000 I'm sorry that's not
the question we asked we didn't ask you
how much money have you made off one
show we asked you the question is did
you charge this much I think the answer
is yes here's what I think happens
Oliver Anthony said he wanted to bring
in his buddy to do his booking
and uh I imagine his buddy booked this
venue event and they say you know how
much how much does Oliver Anthony want
for for this night and he says 120 000
is going rate right now and they said
all right we could make that happen they
set the ticket prices accordingly if you
were to if you were to take uh so a
venue is going to have 80 to 90 of their
tickets are going to be 90 bucks so the
90 to 200 range is overwhelmingly going
to be 90 90 because those are like
standing room and and some seats VIP is
going to be a small amount I did the
math on this 1500 people at that price
it's going to come out to uh I think
like 150 000 if Oliver Anthony's
charging 120k then they got to pay taxes
fees and everything break even sounds
about right I think Oliver Anthony's
crew made the mistake of not realizing
what it meant to charge that much money
then probably had a backlash in charging
so much for the show said no we don't do
that so the venue cancels and now
they're they're in over their head but
I'm curious your thoughts Phil I don't
know
um
what his situation is I mean
there is a lot that goes into you know
putting on a show it's not just one dude
showing up uh with a guitar and stuff I
don't know if it likely was just an
experience it likely was somewhere
someone said oh you know we should get
this kind of money or whatever they
didn't do the math but you can go to any
venue and you can literally do the math
as to how many people can fit in how
much you you know how much it costs for
the overhead for the place how much all
of your staff is going to cost your
security how much you're going to have
to pay your uh your your other bands or
whatever your other acts that are
Insurance all yeah all the whole nine so
this venue probably said we'll break
even on this because we're going to sell
out and sell boost so it works out for
us and then it means ticket prices are
through the roof and usually artists
will go in and they'll try and take as
much of the ticket prices they can like
take if I if if All That Remains can go
into a venue and take all the ticket
money we will like we'll be like this is
what we want you know we know what it's
going to cost we know what you're going
to make and we know what blah blah this
is how much we want to play and where
the entertainment to bring people in and
suppose is yours exactly and because
they're going to make 10 times what they
pay us on booze so I want everyone you
know everybody who went to the Austin
event
we lost money doing that we we I think
we I think we lost I I I want to be
careful because numbers are are serious
business so I don't know the exact
amount but I am pretty sure based on the
accounting we probably lost around 10
grand doing that uh we sold tickets we
sold out the show the tickets were like
130 to 50 bucks expensive and we we lost
money uh it's not easy to do this stuff
and so I I think when you see something
like this these guys
forced full speed into the Limelight the
first guy to ever break onto the charts
at number one with no history ever yeah
that's wow and then he gets his buddy to
do his booking his buddies probably just
like man look how much we can charge and
the venue's like you got it boss we'll
charge it we know you got the draw and
then they were shocked to find their
working class fans can't afford to pay
for it why would you why were you not
then be like okay I'll take 60 000
instead
well the I mean if he's already sold the
tickets right they have to refund them
yeah like there's nothing the venue can
do so I bet he went to them and said hey
guys why is it so expensive and they
said well we gotta we're paying you it's
like it do the math uh you're going to
be doing 1400 tickets at 90 bucks it's
127 000 we got we got ticket fees we got
taxes the VIP stuff is is only a handful
of tickets maybe like 10 to 20 of them
and then he probably said okay I'll take
less just drop it and they're like we
would have to refund everybody and he's
like yeah that's a nightmare so
that's probably why because the venue
Cotton Eye Joe they said they canceled
on their own so yeah I wonder I wonder
if look I hate the ragging the guy but I
wonder if he just went and said hey
waste like it too expensive and they
were like well that's the cost of how
much it's gonna to do this and he said
no I refuse to do the show if you're
charging this much and they said fine
yeah I mean it was definitely I don't I
don't imagine that the dude was is like
oh I'm gonna try and cash in and grab
100 Grand or whatever like like you know
as if this one show is gonna be like the
the big cash grab for his life you know
what I mean anybody that's got a a song
that that is doing well the thing you're
thinking of is how am I going to make
sure that I can follow this up they're
filling it out yeah so yeah he might be
he's so I I do think that you know it's
it's a bad look for him to be charging
for it to cost this much but I have a
feeling that it was all because of
inexperienced people being tossed into
the deep end without knowing how this
this the business works yeah this is my
best friend or one of your good friends
to do a job they don't know man Maduro
in Venezuela you get a bus driver to run
a country what do you think is going to
happen but this is why you don't hear
stories about about big rock bands
dealing with these kinds of things it's
it's rare it's unsurprising that a dude
who's not used to this level of of you
know magnitude is having this issue I
mean this is what happens and look being
a booking agent is a massive pain in the
dick all right you have to get you have
to like you're literally getting venues
all over the place to figure you have to
figure out when you can send this person
to blah blah it has to be within a
certain amount of distance because you
have to be able to make it I don't know
if he's got a bus buses have to have a
skirt you can only have so much dry uh
distance you have to turn it off all
kinds of didn't uh Queen get
electrocuted or was it was that which
band got electrocuted a lot of bands
right so probably so there's that famous
story about the brown M M's Metallica he
got caught on fire yeah yeah yeah yeah
so let me explain for for people like
when we do an event we're doing Tim cast
iron live in Miami we do it it it this
is not what it is it is not we all fly
to Miami have stage set up and then do
the show yeah no it is uh nine months
ago we sent our events coordinator uh uh
first our events coordinator started
researching venues then flew down to
Miami to have meetings with several
different venues to figure out what can
accommodate how many people we can
expect to bring in uh what kind of venue
can accommodate our kind of audience the
politics of the matter so we have to
spend a couple thousand dollars on
travel and accommodation and salary for
the individual to go down and do that
then once we finally do decide on a
venue they want to deposit which is
several thousand dollars more then we
have to send down tech crew and the
coordinator again to start doing prep
work and setting and preparing for the
technology to figuring out how we're
gonna set the show who's going to sit
where what kind of camera is going to be
in what position we have to probably
send crew out there back and forth uh
and then once we get closer to the event
date here's what else we have to do in
order for us to be able to do it we need
accommodations for our entire crew and
the show Tim Castillo for the week of
the event which means not only are we
paying for the venue we now have to find
a sweet Penthouse or house where we can
build a temporary podcast Studio to host
the show for the week which is then why
we have to send out the event
coordinator and the tech people once
again to build another studio so it is
really difficult to do when you're
talking about these big bands and you're
like Hey we're going to be passing
through the city they've got tour buses
the costs are not just what you see at
the venue so when he's saying like I
need 120k there's so much other stuff
around with this venue has to do outside
of what he has to do it's easy for a
dude who's like played small local shows
gonna get up his acoustic guitar and
sing to be prepared for this especially
if you're coming from humble beginnings
but I think this is what happens when
look when I first started uh doing
public speaking
I think my rate was like two thousand
dollars to have me come speak somewhere
why that's what I was worth it covered
my costs it was a good amount for a
single day's work speaking for two hours
but the agency that repped me had people
getting paid fifty thousand dollars and
I was like what the like how is
that person who's not in the Press not
getting attention it doesn't have the
demand charging so much more it was an
entirely different experience these
individuals were famous for best-selling
books and they would craft a
presentation for the event and I was a
flavor of the month showing up for an
hour to talk about what just happened in
the Press I learned that lesson
had I not known it and got invited to
speak somewhere like this I'd be like I
think I should get large sums of cash
and then they'd be like oh whatever you
say I never did that but I'm not
surprised it's it's happened to them
well that's because you did mention them
it's concerning when a big Superstar
brings their friend on to make some
money on the side like whatever I don't
know I don't want to judge them let me
address Ricky in the members chat he
said buy an RV and make it a mobile
podcast Studio we have two of those we
did it in Austin we did it in Nashville
and the reason we're not doing it again
then you have to send a crew to drive
the vehicle down with a CDL a commercial
driver's license yep because the weight
of the RV and the truck exceed the limit
for a standard personal recreational
vehicle then we have to put all the
equipment inside of it yo then it's like
yeah
Alex Jones installed for us because he's
a good dude a an RV Port hookup because
we knew we would need power but we were
thinking we'll run extension cables out
the windows to power everything and uh
when Alex saw what we were doing he was
like I'm gonna have my guys come and
install an RV plug so that you have you
have power throughout the whole unit and
we were like dude wow it's only a couple
hundred bucks to do but it was it was an
awesome thing to do because we didn't
ask him he just went and did it we did
it in Nashville as well
and for Nashville there was no RV hookup
we had to run like five extension cables
into the daily wires building to make
this happen and then we were like wow
it's probably easier to drive a single
truck with the equipment and rent a rent
a building what we're doing now is we're
going to rent an actual Production
Studio and then build out a set design
for the week
if we want to do these shows where we go
on the road this is why we've only done
like two so we've done one so far we're
doing another one
if we're going to do more of these this
is what is required to be able to have
Tim cast IRL Monday through Friday
Monday through Thursday in our studio
and then Friday live it is incredibly
difficult and I I believe it's fair to
say the only reason that we will make
money in Miami is because Public Square
is awesome and sponsored the
event so I think we likely would have
lost
um relative to the cost of this event
the tickets and the say and the size of
the venue
we would lose a comparable amount of
money which is cool because it means we
made a lot more but we lose money doing
it but I I think it's important to bring
people out so that people can meet each
other schmooze they can meet people that
they're fans of we can sell merch and
bring that physical presence to you
which is why I'm hoping you know there's
a lot of people who are saying I'll just
watch it live and I'm like well I get it
it's going to cost like 200 bucks a
person I hope if you can do it you do
show up because you know thanks to
Public Square it's turned into something
very profitable for us that's awesome
but when we're setting these events up
we can't cross our fingers and hope
Public Square will save the day and and
make it something that'll work for us
because when we're setting this up we're
like okay how much do we expect to lose
off this event well if we charge 175 per
ticket we'll probably lose 10 grand I'm
like
all right we can lose that you know like
we have the members already pay enough
to subsidize this and the public events
are good for a lot of different reasons
a lot of different ways and we're hoping
that sponsors eventually come in to pick
up the show the initial sponsorships
that we had planned were going to put us
just above even and then Public Square
came in and they're like guys we want to
sponsor the whole event we want to be
the main sponsors and we're going to
make it worth your while and we're like
dude this just basically saved the day
these guys are awesome we're huge fans
but uh that's the inside baseball there
that uh you know I want to talk about so
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time